ciao a tutti ragazzi il giorno in cui ha
aperto questo canale sapevo che questo
momento sarebbe arrivato il mondo del
beauty si accorto di qualche settimana
fa carni ma mandato questi prodotti 1 al
carbone l'altro all'argilla bianca che
servono per purificare la pelle e
pulirla dalle varie imperfezioni ora io
ho cercato di spiegare loro che doveva
esserci stato un piccolo malinteso
perché io sono perfetto però loro hanno
insistito proprio ricordo ancora la tipa
che mi fa dai con gli almo sarebbe
perfetto se tu utilizzassi questo
momento per lo so parlare magari di
qualche tuo difetto a mandargli un
messaggio che nessuno è perfetto tesoro
mio sì certo guarda sarebbe stupendo
peccato che io sono pazzesco sono
l'incrocio fra grandi e un tronista di
uomini e donne
peccato che del primo abbia preso
l'aspetto del secondo l'intelligenza e
poi scherzi a parte non mi va di fare
l'elenco delle cose che non mi piacciono
di me e sulla confezione c'è scritto tra
in 1a detergente scrub maschera si
ottimisti io sono il modello avanzato
io sono 30 in uno tipo i giorni del mese
o 300 come il film con gerard butler su
start a quello dove alla fine muoiono
tutti e 300 però alla fine ho deciso di
accettare
in primo luogo perché sto perdendo la
faccia cioè proprio in senso letterale
perdo pezzi le faccia faccio tipo hansel
e gretel che per paura di perdere la via
asse milano la ghiaia ecco no io invece
mi perdo queste break all e di pelle in
modo da poter ritrovare la strada per
casa nel momento in cui mi perdo nel
bosco se vi piace più l'immaginario sono
tipo nagini presente faccio la muta
senza contare che chiedo scusa ai più
deboli di cuore io sono stanco di
mattina di mettermi davanti allo
specchio e trivellare alla ricerca del
petrolio a quest'ora sarei uno sciocco
miliardario calcolate che sto messo così
male che ho smesso di chiamarli punti
neri ormai richiamo punti di sospensione
perché se non sono in gruppo
proprio non si palesano io mi sveglio e
li vedo lì queste linee tratteggiate
tipo quelle della settimana enigmistica
non so se avete presente quelle che se
tipo le unisce
ne esce una forma tipo di un animale o
di un oggetto ecco io se l'è unisco
viene la faccia della mia estetista con
sottoscritto quando cazzo vieni quindi
sì direi che mann darmeli non è stata
una scelta sbagliata
maledetta e poi mi piace questo concept
che c'è dietro questa campagna cioè di
parlare dei propri difetti specialmente
in un'epoca in cui facciamo di tutto per
nasconderli pare fatto apposta ma è un
periodo del quale veramente ho bisogno
particolare di parlare a de bella l'idea
di poter fare il proprio lavoro
mentre si parla di cose in cui si crede
perciò allacciate le cinture
mettetevi comodi perché quello che sto
per dirvi potrebbe arrivare come uno
shock e non sono perfetto lo so è
difficile da credere non so
anzi a dirla tutta sono quanto di più
lontano esista della perfezione certo
così esagerato già non è che sono stata
ma però allo stesso tempo non sono
nemmeno madre natura di ciao darwin
basti solo pensare che sto applicando
una maschera senza un cerchietto
qualcosa per portarmi dietro i capelli
già la dice tutta in totale onestà sono
una persona normale mi impegno a fare la
cosa giusta e più delle volte mi accorgo
di farlo nel modo sbagliato prima che
pensate male però sappiate che faccio
anche l'opposto cioè faccio anche la
cosa sbagliata nel modo giusto della
serie peggior non se po sono una persona
fortunata
il che vuol dire che se c'è una sfiga di
base mettercela sono io faccio certi
infantili sono superficiale o una
costanza paragonabile solamente a quella
di una farfalla e vivevo un solo giorno
e non si deve preoccupare la settimana
dopo di tornare in palestra mi dico solo
che mi hanno detto è utilizzare questi
prodotti all'interno di una routine
quotidiana per tipo avere il massimo
dell'efficacia o alla parola routine già
avevo i tremori e vedevo una luce alla
fine del tunnel
ultimamente ho avuto modo di pensare
tanto è un giorno allo specchio mi sono
detto cresci cazzo ti tocca anzi cresci
cazzo ti tocca basta pensare che le
persone attorno a noi siano costrette a
convivere con i nostri difetti solamente
perché ci sono troppo una parte di noi
quindi ci devi stare no perché un
bambino che si sbrodola e tanto
simpatico ed è divertente un adulto che
si sbrodola lo spettacolo abominevole
basta
altri degli alibi per abbandonarci ma
perché lo facciamo per avere una
spiegazione del motivo perché ci
sentiamo soli essere imperfetti e tosta
ma è alla base di quello che siamo
persone si allontanano le opportunità
fanno lo stesso neanche a partire il tuo
corpo vogliono più stare coppette cadoni
capello l'arrivo dell'inverno pezzi li
faccia ti si staccano emigrano per casa
tipo le rondini vabbè qualche giorno fa
mi si è staccata un'unghia del piede
così a buffo della serie causa me ne
vado solo una donna indipendente non
voglio più stare con queste altre io non
immagino poi bloccata nel calzino adesso
come faccio a uscire sinceramente non so
che problemi abbia con coi piedi c'è
unghie e migliorini che si vanno a
sfracellare all'uci valdi veramente io a
volte con fondo le mie scarpe con il
contenitore dei bastoncini lo shanghai
che poi non sono l'unico ad avere
problemi coi piedi chissà perché boh
sarà che anche grazie a loro se cammino
il problema è che cammino anche quando
non ho assolutamente idea di dove andare
se devo fare una scelta non è che faccia
come gli adulti cioè che mi fermo
davanti al vive faccio non vedere un
attimo e cosa ok qui c'è scritto
salvezza ok perfetto
vediamo un pochino cosa c'è scritto un
altro lato merda direi che la scelta è
abbastanza abbastanza ovvio no no io
prendo vado sparato cos'è un bene che
cosa certo fece largo cosa merda un
perfetto è l'anagramma di prima dritti
ma assunto assurdo io assurdo così mi
chiedo da che cosa potrebbe mai
succedere
cioè dai ok sbagli ma che cos'è che ti
potrebbe mai capitare di terribile
massimo si recupera se fai un piccolo
errore lo dico io che cosa può succedere
terribile è presente una doccia ecco
mangiano della per sette giorni di fila
presente questa crema il bagno che ci
deve fare uno scrub non tre volte a
settimana
tre volte al giorno come pasti essa fa e
non parliamo dei pasti che riesco a
essere incoerente anche in quelle avete
presente che dicono che la dieta
perfetta preveda una colazione dare un
pranzo da principi è una scena da poveri
ecco chi one preferiscono altri faccio
la dieta della guerra praticamente
mangio come un esercito e piango come
chi si appresta a morire io proprio
minguccio e poi me ne pento e l'unica
cosa che mi piace degli giorni che
finisce col 1 e anche la durata dei
giorni delle medie 3 e la cosa
divertente è che la stessa cosa la
faccio con le persone cieche bulimico
nel senso più tradizionale del termine e
chi come me
e bulimico gli effetti per cui alla fine
mingozzi negozi negozio di persone che a
un certo punto non ce la faccio più e le
butto via e non posso più nemmeno
guardarle come con un superalcolico dopo
che ti sei preso una sbronza vado avanti
come lo yin e lo yang è tratto la
filosofia in maniera incoerente e cerco
di fare dell'incoerenza una filosofia di
vita così mi trovo percorrere binari
opposti allo stesso momento amore odio
the rita e menzogna di pane palestra
voglia di barbecue e di cena vegana allo
stesso tempo quasi fossi un alchimista
che cerca di unire fuoco e acqua nella
speranza di trovare la pietra filosofale
il problema è che l'unica pietra che mi
ritrovo in mano e quella pollice che
continua a sfregare contro i talloni
nella speranza di eliminare i calli che
mi sono fatto a furia di percorrere la
strada sbagliata con la quadra è
continuato armi in fronte nella speranza
di aggiustarmi il cervello come si fa
con un elettrodomestico rotto il
problema che a me è capitato il
frullatore quindi quando l'attivo col
cervello ci faccio un frappè vigerà
avrei fatto anche un elenco di tutte le
cose che non mi piacciono a livello
fisico perché in teoria era quello
l'intento fidatevi che ne ho un sacco ma
parlando mi sono reso conto che la lista
delle cose che non mi piacciono a
livello caratteriale faceva impallidire
la prima ha così preferito ritirarmi
come un calzino analizzarmi per quello
che ho dentro
che poi è quello che sono invece che
parla del superficiale del quello che vi
mostro per il profilo di turno per
qualsiasi imperfezione per i puntini di
voi potete trovare facilmente un alleato
ma la cosa difficile trovare un alleato
che mi stia vicino per tutte le
imperfezioni che mette dentro qualcuno
che riesco a farmi sentire levigati
purificati san san martin e punti neri
non tanto qui ma qui è la cosa
divertente che quella persona molto
probabilmente la conoscete la incontrate
ogni mattina anche se gonfia di sonno
davanti allo specchio e quella verso una
sete se quella persona non impara a
trovare un equilibrio tra quello che
mostra è quello che tiene dentro e non
impara a prendersi cura di quello che ha
dentro così come fa con quello che ha
fuori
secondo me perde un pochino di
importanza preoccuparsi dei denti storti
e forse acquista più significato il
chiedersi perché non si sorride mai e
magari il vero cambiamento per il quale
dobbiamo sperare e cominciare a darci
dei motivi per farlo ogni giorno
ciao
comunque posso dire che funziona ragazze
si sentiva dalle cronache a motivo qui
c'era gratis
senti la faccia oddio io inserisco
minchia liscio come un vino è capito in
chiaro no per te no